[Music]
i might have to go to see the zamboni
but no it was it was great
okay we'll go
sorry
tampa bay lightning captain steven
stamkos was trying to give a press
conference at last month's all-star game
but his son had other ideas as you heard
watching as zamboni seems to bring out
the kid in all of us the groundbreaking
machine has been featured in movies
cartoons and even made into kids toys in
fact the zamboni brand is so well known
most people think that is what all ice
resurfacers are called though there are
competitors it's the 73 year old zamboni
machine that paved the way for ice
sports as we know them today
this massive machine may bear the name
of what could be an italian race car
driver but the zamboni isn't exactly
built for speed
how fast are we going
it doesn't have a speedometer
i don't think we're going over 20. just
under 10 actually but the ride is smooth
and that's the point unless you're just
out for a joyride it is a very nice view
chris jennings manages the ice for the
nhl's philadelphia flyers can you
imagine if you still had to do this with
the shovel
i can imagine it i don't want to you
know i don't want to do that but yeah i
can imagine it
that's how ice was resurfaced before
1949. that's you
that's been
in younger times it changed when richard
zamboni's father frank created the model
a he started with a just a tractor and a
planer that didn't work
and he finally
got something in his mind he says well
i'll do something different is there all
war surplus
wheels the prototype made of spare
aircraft parts from a local junkyard
took frank seven years to develop
zamboni used crushed walnut shells to
give the tires traction an ingenious
design from a guy who never made it past
ninth grade says the company's brand
manager paula cooney he worked on a farm
and
actually his parents pulled him out of
school because they needed help her on
the farm so he was constantly working on
tractors and fixing things and so he was
mechanically inclined frank zamboni
moved off the farm and into another
family business locally there were a lot
of dairy farmers and produce farmers so
they used they made block ice okay and
with the advent of the refrigerator
coming around the corner they kind of
said we're gonna have to do something
else with our refrigeration equipment so
they knew that there was a big dutch
community here and skating was a thing
so they went from blocks of ice to a
sheet in january 1940 opening paramount
iceland this skating rink
then came frank's inspiration for the
zamboni he was always a really smart
businessman he realized really quickly
that it was taking four or five people
about an hour to an hour and a half to
manually resurface the ice and you know
the cost of the building in general
time is money and he wanted to find
something that would help
take some of that time back in 1954 the
boston bruins became the first nhl team
to purchase a zamboni after seeing it
used for the ice capades by 1960 zamboni
machines were resurfacing ice at the
olympic games in [ __ ] valley california
it was an invention so popular that it
accidentally cut into chicago blackhawks
owner arthur wertz's bottom line and he
apparently was annoyed because people
didn't want to leave their seats to go
to the concessions to like go get their
hot dogs and their sodas so um he he saw
that as a downside of having the zamboni
machine so there was fascination there
was definitely fascination and there and
there still is over the years the basic
concept of a zamboni hasn't changed too
much
a super sharp
57-pound blade shaves a thin layer off
the ice while fresh ice-making water is
distributed evenly across the ice and
smoothed by a spreader towel
[Music]
the shavings are put into a tank and
dumped off to the side ladies first oh
thank you thank you as long as i don't
fall right the roughly six minute
process leaves behind a perfect sheet of
ice to skate on you know how smooth it
is you can never achieve it with just
shoveling it's just impossible figure
skater ilya kulik won the gold medal at
the 1998 winter olympics it's just the
speed wise
and the
pretty much no it changed the whole
industry it changed the whole sports of
figure skating and hockey and speed
skating very nice today the 44 year old
is busy teaching a new generation in the
sport but he knows his way around the
ice in more ways than one you owned a
zamboni yes yes
it was my best my best toy pretty much
my best yeah i had my ring my training
ring training facility for four years
did you drive to zamboanga yeah
absolutely for four years no no no you
know the real genius is is simplicity
and that machine is just it's just so
simple to operate i had the i had the
electric unit which was also fantastic
green
no exhaust nothing the simple motors
everything worked like a charm the
family run company is still based in
paramount california where that first
zamboni machine was built they are still
made to order and built by hand the 48
thousand square foot factory sits about
a half mile from the iceland rink so
close you might see a half-built machine
just driving by are you producing more
electric than fuel powered zamboni we
are now staff engineer kelly mcmillin
showed us the latest models including
lithium-ion battery-powered machines at
this point it's decided whether it be an
electric machine or a fuel powered
machine we've got an axle layout that
has drive shafts connected to a gearbox
and a look under the hood that's a
horizontal auger that's basically
conveying all the snow to the center a
machine so complicated yet so simple
providing a service that will never dry
up as skaters some good i agree with
that be careful
some not so much tackle the ice i might
be a better zamboni driver than figure
skater well you can give it a try
maybe but probably better left to the
pros
you're like right up against it
oh yeah
all right so some cool things my near
falling aside thank you it had been a
while frank is in the nhl and the figure
skating hall of fames for that invention
because it obviously changed everything
and that olympics we mentioned [ __ ]
valley that's what helped it go
worldwide because everybody saw what it
can do and it's just amazing to see a
family company still working like it
does and yes it was very cool to ride on
the zamboni i don't care that it was
going just under 10 miles an hour that
was awesome right
count me in the club of the kids who sat
there and watched the zamboni during
sabres games intermissions instead of
going to get pretzels
no yeah i didn't
yeah i was watching during jack's hockey
games we see them come out there are
still people that watch there's no doubt
great piece thanks thank you thank you